[Music]
malice you know what i'm talking about
that gooey reddish purplish evil
substance that coats many parts of the
land of hyrule and is shown to be
spewing infinitely out of the corpse of
ganondorf forget everything you know
about it at least just for this video
because what i'm about to talk to you
about goes against all of the other
popular theories on what malice is such
as the theory that it's always been a
monster life force of sorts that
manifests as a purple colored cloud when
an enemy creature dies or the theory
that it is the very same substance as
the evil crystals from skyward sword
this theory that i'm going to talk to
you about is so different and so crazy
that it just might work it's also kind
of nasty in that ew grows kind of way so
you know forewarning here let's get
right into it malice is all over the
place in breath of the wild it's in the
overworld in sheikah technologies and
even in the depths and heart of hyrule
castle itself in fact every form of
ganon we encounter in the game is
completely made of this malice substance
in the breath of the wild 2 trailer we
can see where we assume malice
originated from ganondorf in the trailer
we see him as this mummified dude that's
just sitting there spewing a bunch of
thick tendril-like malice out of his
body well have you ever wondered how
exactly this rather dry looking
mummified body of ganondorf is just
spewing a limitless amount of malice out
of it the immediate thought here is that
this is happening as a result of the
original curse of the demon tribe
introduced to us by demise who stated
that an incarnation of his hatred would
forever follow those who carried the
blood of the goddess and the spirit of
the hero that's pretty easy to
understand but it's when we try to
connect that ancient curse with this
actual tangible eyeball-filled goop
found all over breath of the wild that
the theories start happening it's
because this is the first time we've
ever seen malice also known as evil
represented tangibly like this and in
this quantity and it's also the first
time we've ever seen ganondorf wielding
or producing any kind of power that
doesn't stem from either his own wizard
abilities or the triforce of power much
less while being you know dead the
question i'd like to ask here is this
even if demise's malicious intent has
existed in some way for the entirety of
the zelda franchise which i'm not
questioning what happened to make it
manifest specifically this way in breath
of the wild what made malice breath of
the wild has long been speculated as
being heavily inspired by the works of
studio ghibli particularly the movie
called princess mononoke i mean fans of
the film will pretty clearly see the
visual resemblances between link and the
film's protagonist ashitaka they're both
youthful boys who dress in tunics and
hoodies wielding bows and arrows and
swords riding through very green fields
on the backs of their trusty steeds they
also both have hearts of gold and epic
combat skills i happen to believe that
malice is also inspired by a substance
we see in princess mononoke spoiler
warning for those who haven't seen the
movie by the way near the end of the
film the humans led by lady aboshi
remove the head of the dear god turning
its body into a corrupted version of the
nightwalker spilling sentient goop all
over the land that removes the life of
anything it comes in contact with this
corrupted dear god goop is what i
believe malice was inspired by as well
both are similarly goopy are sentient
and will destroy life on contact they're
also both of a similar coloration but
there is one more similarity that the
substances share that we weren't able to
see until the breath of the wild 2
trailer and that is the fact that in
either case the goopy substance
originates from an individual in the
film the mononoke malice originates from
the deer god's body and in breath of the
wild malice comes from ganondorf's
corpse but the reason why i'm taking so
long to cover their similarities is to
point out the fact that mononoke malice
wasn't created without something
happening to its point of origin the
deer god and i believe the same could be
true for ganondorf the deer god stimulus
was its head being removed making the
mononoke malice spread but ganondorf
still has his head could something else
have happened to his body that resulted
in the creation of malice well let me
set something up real quick before
answering that in breath of the wild we
can see the minions of ganon everywhere
but their quote-unquote leader calamity
gannon is a mindless monster who is
incapable of speech how could this
amalgamation of weaponry and goop have
possibly intelligently formulated armies
and led forces against hyrule well let
me tell you a story once upon a time the
legend of zelda was a new franchise 35
years ago in fact the first zelda game
was so well received that nintendo made
a sequel and this sequel was called
zelda 2 and because it was a direct
sequel it had to take place after the
events of the original game this was
before the sloppy timeline stuff anyway
so story wise since link defeated ganon
at the end of the first game ganon was
effectively dead in the second game but
yet his minions ran around the world of
hyrule trying to kill link just the same
but why you ask their leader was dead so
they should have just you know given up
right well in the official game manual
we're given some insight into the
reasoning behind ganon's monsters still
roaming about you see they wanted to
kill link so that they could then drain
the blood from his body and sprinkle it
over the ashes of the evil king doing so
according to this official manual would
revive ganon now back to breath of the
wild i'm not trying to say for certain
which timeline the game takes place in
but many people already believe it takes
place at the end of the fallen timeline
matpat from game theory even has a
pretty compelling theory about this
placement as well if this is the case
then that places breath of the wild
immediately after zelda 2 in the
timeline the last thing we knew about
ganon was that he was indeed dead but
his minions were trying to revive him
with the blood of the link that killed
him the link from zelda 1. we can only
assume that the minions were trying to
accomplish what we saw them attempting
to do in zelda 2 and that is to find
link and revive ganon and what we are
left with in the game breath of the wild
is a revived form of ganon created out
of malice by the way have you ever
wondered why malice seems oddly familiar
as a substance i mean it's this weird
dark reddish purplish goop that we've
never seen in a video game before but it
is very similar to a certain real-life
substance that everyone is familiar with
blood malice has many similarities to
coagulated blood such as its goopy
sticky sometimes stringy nature and
deeply red color calamity ganon's
resurrection cocoon in the royal chamber
of hyrule castle is even stylized to
resemble a hanging human heart and has
veins delivering malice to and from the
cocoon much like our blood vessels
deliver blood to and from our hearts the
creations of pure malice the ganons are
all oddly shaped because they have no
actual solid form they're just globs of
coagulated malice with shika technology
scattered throughout their bodies and
they bleed out violently when defeated
the final piece to this blood puzzle
would be the fact that malice has been
shown to originate from ganondorf's
corpse giving even more credence to its
similarities to blood but the final
question remains if malice is a form of
corrupted blood that's coming from
ganondorf's corpse why is his blood so
powerful and infinitely limitless well
what if it's not just his blood but the
corrupted blood of link from zelda 2. if
you think about it the only way to
ensure that link's blood from zelda 2
wouldn't be used for the revival of
ganon would be to hide link's body away
after he dies of his eventual natural
death given that link was able to even
avoid being killed and captured by
ganon's minions for his entire life in
the first place however keeping
something like that hidden would be
impossibly difficult especially when you
take into consideration the limitless
amount of time that ganon's minions have
to roam about searching for the body so
what if they eventually were successful
and did in fact pour link's blood onto
the corpse of ganondorf after the events
of zelda 2 corrupting it with demise's
malicious hatred that resided within
ganondorf and turning it into malice
with the sole purpose of reviving ganon
that would explain why even though
malice is an obviously supernatural
substance that spreads infinitely and
can even corrupt pools of water in
hyrule to spread further it ultimately
serves to form ganons over and over
again and at certain intervals on
certain nights ganon's malice surges in
power across the land of hyrule under
the light of a blood moon so there you
have it my crazy short theory that
malice could actually be the tainted
blood of the hero now how does the green
hand from the trailer tie into all this
i'm not sure to be honest while it does
appear to be some sort of either living
or man-made construct that's attempting
to stop the outward flow of malice from
ganondorf's corpse it also seems to be
not only kind of failing at that job but
also extracting the malice from the body
as nintendo black crisis discovered in a
video last year some people speculate
that it's the soul of a previous link
and with this theory that could imply
that it is the soul of link from zelda 2
trying to do something to prevent the
spread of malice but i digress it's just
too vague to figure out for sure at this
point once again this theory is
definitely a crazy one and not really
even one that i 100 subscribe to but
it's too interesting to ignore in my
opinion plus you guys know i love doing
videos like this that just make people
think about something different than
usual that being said though what do you
think am i onto something here and
malice was created from the tainted
blood of a previous hero or is that way
off and malice is just you know an
unexplained goop thing now let me know
in the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching i had a lot of fun
making this theory and hope you enjoyed
the watch either way please consider
dropping a like below to get this video
spread around on youtube and clicking
that subscribe button to stick around
for more zelda and nintendo content to
come as always huge thanks to all of my
fantastic supporters of which i have
some amazing new faces to introduce
first and foremost i have a new super
supporter named bloody pirate who joined
the ranks of my elite at the top tier
thank you so much i also have rhiannon
and joseph r gabrielle autumn and the b
ceradooka who have all joined the ranks
as well thank you all so very much you
have more of an impact on this channel
than you'll ever know if any of you
watching are interested in helping the
next video come to life feel free to
check out that join button located below
each video or follow the links in the
description to find out how on patreon
also down in that description area are
the links to my social media pages so if
you want to see the kinds of nonsense i
post like this right here come on over
and follow me on twitter that's all i've
got for this video so i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is mass
intended bandit signing out
[Music]
you